No,
I don't think it's ever happened to me before,
although it might have,
but I can't recall.
It's having happened that I found myself lecturing on a person who had lectured
yesterday,
here at Yale.
But that's what happened.
In this case.
You read,
um,
let's just call it the facetious article on the lecture and the Daily News this
morning.
Some of you may actually have been in attendance.
Um,
I unfortunately could not be a,
but as it happened,
I ran into her later in the evening and talk to some of her colleagues about
what she'd said.
So I,
I do have,
um,
uh,
a certain sense,
a certain sense of what went on.
Um,
in any case.
Uh,
yeah.
And,
and as to what went on,
um,
I'm going to be talking today about the slippery just phenomenon,
intellectual phenomenon in her essay having to do with what she called psychic x
excess.
That is the charge or excess from the unconscious,
which in some measure up unsettles even that which can be performed.
We perform identity,
we perform our subjectivity,
we've performed gender and all the ways that we'll be discussing in this
lecture,
but beyond what we can perform.
There is sexuality,
which I'm going to be turning to in a minute.
And this has something to do with the,
uh,
authentic realm of the unconscious from which it emerges.
So what Butler did in her lecture yesterday was to return to the psychoanalytic
aspect of the essay that you read for today.
Um,
emphasizing particularly the work of law,
cons,
disciple John Lobb launch,
uh,
and,
and developing the ways in which,
um,
sexuality,
uh,
is something that belongs in a dimension that exceeds a and is less accessible
than those more coded,
uh,
concepts that we think of as gender,
or as identity in general.
Um,
and so,
um,
conveniently enough for those of you who did attend her lecture yesterday,
in many ways,
she really did return to the issues that concerned her at the period of her
career when she wrote gender trouble.
And when she wrote the essay that you read for today.
All right.
Now I do want to begin with what ought to be an innocent question.
I mean,
surely we were entitled to an answer to this question.
And the question is,
what is sexuality right now?
Of course,
you may be given pause,
especially if you've got an ear fine tuned to jargon.
You may be given pause by that very word,
sexuality,
which is obviously relatively recent in the language people didn't use to talk
about sexuality.
They talked about sex,
which,
you know,
seems somehow more straight forward.
Um,
but the,
but,
but sexuality is a term,
uh,
which is not only pervasive and cultural thought,
but also has a certain privilege.
I'm on other ways of describing that aspect of our lives.
In other words,
there's something authentic,
uh,
as I've already began to suggest about our sexuality,
something more authentic about that.
Then,
uh,
the sorts of aspects of ourselves that we can and do perform.
That's,
that's Butler's argument.
Uh,
and it's an interesting starting point,
but it's really not.
It's,
it's not yet,
or perhaps not at all.
An answer to the question,
what is sexuality?
No for food co actuality,
uh,
is arguably something like desired and experienced bodily pleasure.
But the problem is that this pleasure is always orchestrated by a set of
factors,
uh,
that surround it.
A very complicated set of factors,
which is arc articulated perhaps best,
um,
on paid 1634 in his text.
Uh,
the lower right hand column,
he's talking about the difference between and the interaction between,
uh,
what he calls the deployment of alliance and the deployment of our word
sexuality.
Uh,
and I want to read this passage and then comment on it briefly
in a word.
And it's of course not in a word,
it's several words.
The deployment of alliance is attuned to a homeostasis of the social body.
The deployment of alliance is the way in which in a given culture,
the nuclear reproductive unit is defined typically as the family,
but the family in itself changes in its nature and its structure and the way in
which the family is viewed,
the sorts of activities that are supposed to take place and not take place in
the family.
Because Fuko lays a certain amount of stress on incest.
And the,
and the atmospheric threat of incest,
the sorts of things that go on in the family and are surrounded by certain kinds
of discourse conveying knowledge.
Uh,
and we'll come back to,
to,
to the latter part of that sentence,
all have to do with the deployment of alliance,
the deployment of sexuality.
Uh,
on the other hand,
the deployment of sexuality,
we understand as the way in which whatever it,
this thing is that we're trying to define,
uh,
is talked about,
and therefore,
uh,
not by any state apparatus or actual legal system necessarily,
but nevertheless,
simply by,
um,
the,
uh,
the prevalence and force of various sorts of knowledge,
policed.
Okay.
To continue the passage in a word,
the deployment of alliance is attuned to a homeostasis or regularization.
That's what,
that's what he means by homeostasis of the social body,
which it has the function of maintaining went it's privileged link with the law.
That is to say the law tells us all fit all sorts of things about the family,
including whether or not there can be gay marriage.
Just incidentally,
I'll,
I'll come back to that in a minute.
It's to the fact that the important phase for it is reproduction.
The deployment of sexuality has its reason for being not in reproducing itself,
but in Liferay innovating a Nexin,
creating and penetrating bodies in an increasingly detailed way and in
controlling populations in an increasingly comprehensive way.
What he's saying is among other things that a deployment of sexuality,
which isn't necessarily a bad thing,
these deployments aren't meant somehow or another to be terroristic regimes.
Uh,
a deployment of sexuality,
which for example,
favored forms of sexuality such as birth control or homosexuality,
uh,
would certainly be a means of controlling reproduction.
That is to say,
and,
and just in that degree,
the deployment of sexuality could be seen as subtly or not so subtly at odds
with the deployment of alliance alliance,
which is all for the purpose of reproduction or at least takes as its primary
sign as food goes,
suggests the importance in [inaudible] to a given culture or socio biological
system,
if you will,
of reproduction.
And so this is the way,
these are the ways in which the deployment of alliance and the deployment of
sexuality converge don't converge conflict with each other.
Uh,
but in all of these ways,
um,
we keep seeing this concept of sexuality.
But as I say,
it continues to be somewhat elusive.
What precisely it is.
Um,
just to bracket that for the moment,
let me make another comment or two on the concept in the passage that I've just
read,
let's say once for all at the outset that the central idea in food costs tax,
the idea of which he continues to develop throughout the three volumes on the
history of sexuality.
Uh,
the,
the central idea is this idea of power as something other than that which is
enforced through legal policing or state apparatus means power,
which is enforced as a circulation or distribution of knowledge,
which is discursive in nature,
which enforces its norms for all of us.
For better or for worse.
Because discourse can release,
can constitute sites of resistance as well as oh press,
which for better or worse,
circulates among us ideas that are in a certain sense,
governing ideas about whatever it is that's in question.
In this case,
obviously sexuality.
So,
and Foodco calls this sometimes,
uh,
hyphenating it power knowledge.
This is absolutely the central idea in late Fuko I introduced it,
you remember last time in talking about site,
I come back to it now as that which really governs and guides you through the
whole text of Fuko,
the distinction between power as it's traditionally understood as Authoritarians
dative as sort of top down coming from above imposed on us by law,
by the police,
by whatever establishment of that kind.
There might be distinction between power of that kind,
uh,
and power,
which is simply the way in which knowledge and knowledge is not by the way,
uh,
necessarily a good word.
It's not necessarily knowledge of the truth,
but the way in which knowledge circulates and,
uh,
imposes its effects on us behavior the way we are or the way,
at least that we think we are.
Uh,
the way in which we perform in Butler's term,
uh,
all of that in Fuko his dick is,
is,
uh,
to be understood as an effect of power knowledge.
Now notice,
however,
in terms of our question,
what is sexuality?
That Fuko is being quite coy.
He's talking about sexuality,
but he's not talking about it in itself.
Whatever it in itself might be,
he's talking about the deployment of it.
That is to say the way in which power and knowledge constructs it makes it
visible,
makes it available to us,
makes it a channel through which desire can get itself expressed.
But a channel which is still not necessarily in and of itself,
that natural thing that we look for and long for,
uh,
and continue to seek the nature of sexuality.
So when the,
when the emphasis in fruit discussion Israeli on deployment,
that is the way in which alliance,
the family,
whatever the,
whatever the nuclear social structure might be,
or sexuality,
whatever it is that gets itself expressed,
uh,
as desire.
Uh,
the way in which these,
these,
these matters,
these aspects of our,
uh,
of our lives can be deployed.
We still aren't necessarily talking about the thing in itself.
Cuco isn't an anthropologist,
he's not talking about the family in itself either.
He's talking about the way in which a basic concept of alliance out of which
reproduction arises and gets itself channeled,
can be deployed,
understood as manipulated by the circulation of power knowledge.
The issue of gay marriage is very interesting by the way,
between these con,
the concept of the deployment of alliance and the deployment of sexuality
because there's a certain sense in which the deployment of sexuality is at odds
with the deployment of alliance.
If you know,
if sexuality is something that is really just looking around for ways to get
itself expressed,
uh,
you know,
taking advantage of deployment where that's a good thing.
Trying to resist deployment where that seems more like policing.
If it's just looking around for a way to get express,
it's not particularly interested in alliance.
It's not interested in the way in which,
um,
a in which relationships involving sexuality could set her in,
could settle into any kind of a coded pattern or system of regularity.
So that there is this tension,
which of course gets itself expressed whenever within the gay community,
uh,
people strongly support gay marriage and see that as the,
as the politicized center of contemporary gay life or people also in the gay
community.
Many of them theoretically advanced think of as a nonissue or a side issue
which,
which loses track precisely of what Fuko calls the deployment of sexuality.
Simply trying to extend the domain,
arguably a tyrannical domain of the deployment of alliance to extent.
In other words,
in other words,
to redefine the basic concept of alliance in such a way that doesn't really
touch very closely on the deployment of sexuality.
So it's an interesting and rather mixed issue.
Uh,
that the whole question,
the whole sort of profoundly politicized question of gay marriage gives rise to.
So that's what's actuality
is and [inaudible] and Butler,
it's just clearer that to ask the question,
what is sexuality as well?
It's just been a false start.
You know,
we thought it was an innocent question,
but whoa.
You know,
you get into,
you get into Butler and you and,
and you see very clearly that you simply can't be of a certain sexuality.
You can perform and identity as we'll see by repeating,
by imitating,
by parodying in drag.
You can perform an identity,
but you can't wholly perform sexuality precisely because of this element of
psychic excess to which her thinking,
uh,
continues very candidly and openly and honestly to return.
Butler's work in other words is not just about the construction of identity.
It's not just about,
uh,
the domain of performance as one might say.
It acknowledges that there is something,
something very difficult to grasp and articulate beyond performance.
Its main business is to explain the nature and purview and purposes of
performance,
but it's nevertheless always clear in butler,
uh,
as she returns to the question of the unconscious in particular,
that there is something,
uh,
in excess of,
or not fully to be,
uh,
to be encompassed by ideas of performance.
Okay.
So we've made a false start.
We've asked a question we can't answer,
but at the same time we have learned certain things.
We've learned certainly that sexuality,
whatever it is,
is more flexible and also in some sense more authentic.
That is to say closest to the actual nature of the drives.
Yesterday,
uh,
Butler made a distinction between instinct and drive,
which I won't go into because it had to do with her reflections on what is
cultural and what is,
uh,
biological or not cultural in the,
in the life of the unconscious.
But for our purposes,
whatever role sexuality may play in the unconscious,
uh,
and however that,
however authentic that is to say,
however,
not culturally determined,
uh,
that role may turn out to be,
um,
it's more flexible and that's the important thing.
Then any kind of social coding,
the sort of coding for example,
that,
uh,
that Fuko would,
intimate in speaking of alliance or deployed sexuality and the sort of coding
that Butler refers to repeatedly as gendering,
but still for both of them.
And this is the other thing we've learned.
Even sexuality through deployment or through the way in which it can get
expressed in relation to gender and performance,
even sexuality is discursive.
It's a matter of discourse.
It arises out of linguistic formations,
formations that Fuko understands as circulated knowledge and that Butler
understands again as performance Fuko sees sexuality as the effect of power,
knowledge,
power as knowledge.
Butler sees it as the effect,
uh,
as it's insofar as it's visible and so far as it is acted out,
sees it as the effect of performance.
So now to,
to take,
to take the way in which Butler makes this relationship between what one might
suppose to be authentic,
actual about oneself and that which is perform that which that which is one's
constructs to be a self.
Let's take the one of the most provocative sentences in her essay,
which is on page 1711,
about a third of the way down since I was 16,
being a lesbian is what I've been being a lesbian is what I've been now,
what she's doing.
And remember at the very beginning of the essay,
she says that her whole purpose is to reflect is,
is,
is somehow or another to register a politicized intervention in gender studies
in terms of a philosophical reflection on ontology,
on being,
what is it?
In other words,
she says to be something now what she's doing in this sentence,
which is an awkward seeming sense,
being a lesbian is what I've been,
what she's doing is pointing out to us that to be something is very different
from to B being something that,
for example,
you know,
I can say I'm busy by the way I am.
I can say,
I can say I'm busy and I expect you to to to take it,
that there's a certain integrity,
there's a certain authenticity in the fact that I'm busy.
Yes,
I'm busy.
But suppose you say suspecting that I'm not really busy.
Suppose you say,
oh,
he's being busy.
All right?
In other words,
he's performing buisiness,
he's going around being busy,
you know,
so imposing on me.
The idea that this lazy person is actually accomplishing something.
Right?
So the performance of being busy.
But here's the interesting point that Butler is making.
The ontological realm is supposed to be about the simple being or existence of
things.
And it's always in philosophy,
contrasted with agency,
with the doing of things,
with getting something done with the performance of things.
But what Butler is saying and that's why she says that she takes an interesting
in the ontological aspect of the question,
what she's saying is that there's an element of the performative which actually
creeps into the ontological even being,
she says as something that in some measure,
perhaps not altogether,
but in some measure something we perform.
Hence the double mint,
the doubling,
the doubling up of the word being in the sentence.
Since I was 16 being a lesbian is what I've been in one science.
Yeah I am.
That's what I am.
But in another sense I've been performing it.
I've been being why,
ah,
I've been outing myself if you will.
I have been taking up a role that can be understood as all roles can
intelligibly in terms of its performance.
So that's the why she puts the sentence that way.
And if you said if you kind of made a big mark in the margin and said Aha,
got her right,
this is where she says she really is something.
No more of this stuff of just constructivism,
you know,
making,
making oneself up as one goes along.
This is where she says she really is something you're wrong.
She's escaped your criticism because she says,
oh no,
no,
it's be I,
I have been being a lesbian.
I've been being one,
which is a different thing,
although not an altogether different things from being one.
She is deliberately,
in other words,
on the fence between the sense of the ontological as authentic and her own
innovative sense of the ideological as belonging within the realm of
performance.
All right.
And she doesn't want to get off the fence.
She doesn't want she,
she really doesn't want to come down squarely on either side because for her,
and this is what I liked best about her work,
even though it's perhaps the most frustrating thing about it because for her,
what she is talking about is ultimately mysterious.
She has a great deal to about it,
but she's not pretending that in what she has to say about it,
she's exhausted the subject.
That's why it seems to me to be admirable that she stays on the fence about this
and not simply,
um,
uh,
you know,
an occasion for our frustration.
Come on,
come out with it.
I want to know what sexuality,
sorry.
Okay.
All right.
So,
um,
with all this said,
it seems plain that,
and,
and sort of mystification aside if you will as well.
With all this said,
it seems playing that Fuko and Butler do have a common political agenda who co a
gay writer,
uh,
who was,
in the later stages of writing the history of sexuality,
um,
dying of aids,
uh,
Butler,
a lesbian writer,
both of them very much concerned for the political implications of their
marginalized gender roles while at the same time,
um,
of course being theoretically very sophisticated about them.
They're common political agenda is two d stabilize the heteronormative by
denying the authenticity or in Butler's parlance originality of privileged
gender roles.
In other words,
who says heterosexual sexuality came first?
Who says the nuclear family is natural?
Who says sexuality,
AH,
can only get itself expressed in certain ways.
That power knowledge deploys for it.
All right.
These are the sorts of questions,
the,
the politicized questions,
which these discourses raise in common.
Um,
uh,
so it,
so it seems to me that they have a very broad agenda in common and it also seems
to me that they are very closely in agreement.
And so,
and I say that just in order to pause briefly on the moment in which they seem
not to be,
you've probably noticed that um,
one text is referring to another at one point in your reading.
And so let's go there.
Paid 17,
12,
the right hand margin.
Uh,
and the context for this of course is Butler talking about Jesse Helms,
um,
having deplored male homosexuality in attacking the photography of Robert Maple
Thorpe.
Uh,
and by implication,
Butler argues simply erasing female homosexuality because his diatribe pays no
attention to it.
And Butler then complains that there's a certain injustice in that,
um,
because in a way it's even worse,
she says,
uh,
so to be declared nonexistent than it is to be declared deviant,
right?
At least the male homosexual gets to be declared deviant.
We're simply erased.
That's the position she's taking here.
And then at that point and show what.
And so what she says is to be prohibited explicitly is to occupy a discoursive
sight from which something like a reverse discourse can be articulated.
To be implicitly proscribed is not even to qualify as an object of prohibition.
And here's where she,
she gives us a footnote on food.
Go Footnote 15 you know,
we love footnotes.
It is this particular rules of Eraser,
which food co for the most part fails to take account of in his analysis of
power.
Butler's argument is that in food,
in terms,
there's gotta be discourse for there to be identity,
right?
Helms is refusal of the category of lesbian simply by omission because,
and,
and of course we know by the way,
that this is a refusal only by omission.
Helen says,
refusal of this category is at the Sa is,
is,
in other words,
any ratio of discourse.
No discourse,
no identity.
That is,
in other words,
what Butler is claiming,
who co's position and towels.
Discourse creates power.
Knowledge is power.
Knowledge creates identity.
Therefore where there's no discourse,
there can be no identity.
And since Helms has erased the lesbian by refusing discourse about it,
it must follow that there's no such thing as a lesbian,
right.
That,
that,
that's the implication of this footnote.
He almost always presumes,
and we must do honor to that word,
almost almost always presumed that power takes place through discourse as its
instrument and that oppression is linked and that oppression,
sorry,
is linked with subjection and subjective position.
That is that it is installed as the formative principle of the identity of
subjects.
All right?
Now in defense of food co,
let's go to page 1632 the upper right hand column,
a passage that fascinated,
that's fascinating on a number of grounds.
It's rather long.
Um,
but I think I will read it.
Upper right hand column Fuko says,
consider for example the history of what was once the great sin against nature,
the extreme discretion of the texts dealing with sodomy.
That utterly confused category and the nearly universal reticence in talking
about it made possible a twofold operation.
Okay.
Here's food saying this is a category,
the hall of us actual identity as a understood in terms of sodomy as a category.
He's about,
he's going to go on to say that it's a,
that it's punishable in the extreme by law.
But in the meantime he's saying there's no discourse.
That's a kind of almost universal silence on the subject.
You don't get silence.
And Dante,
as I'm sure you know,
uh,
but in most cases in this period,
nobody talks about it.
It's punishable severely punishable by law.
And yet nobody talks about this would seem to violate food coes own premise that
discourse constitutes identity.
Uh,
but also plainly does contradict Butler's claim that Fuko supposes that
discourse always constitutes identity.
So let's continue
the nearly universal reticence and talking about it made possible a twofold
operation.
On the one hand,
there was an extreme severity.
Punishment by fire was meted out well into the 18th century without there being
any substantial protest expressed before the middle of the century.
Discourse is here failing also.
And that it's not constituting a site of resistance.
Nobody is complaining about these severe punishments.
Just as on the other hand,
nobody's talking very much about them.
There is and other words and eraser of discourse and he continues on the other
hand,
a tolerance that must have been widespread,
which one can Dedoose indirectly from the infrequency of judicial sentences and
which one glimpse is more directly through certain statements concerning
societies of men that were thought to exist in the army or in the courts.
In other words,
he's saying there was an identity and that identity was not,
at least not very much constituted by discourse.
And he's going to go on to say,
as you read down the column,
he's going to go on to say that in a way the plight of the homosexual got worse
when it started being talked about.
Yes.
Penalties for being homosexual were less severe,
but the surveillance of of homosexuality,
the way in which it could be,
um,
sort of dictated to by therapy and by the clergy and by everyone else who might
have something to say about it became far more pervasive and determine it.
Then it was when there was no discourse about it.
So that,
um,
in a certain way Fuko has going.
So I'm going so far as to say silence was while perilous to the few a good thing
for the many,
whereas discourse,
uh,
which perhaps relieves the few of extreme fear nevertheless,
so imposes a kind of hedge your monic,
uh,
authority on all that remain and constitutes them as something that power
knowledge believes them to be rather than something that in any sense according
to their sexuality,
they spontaneously are.
So it seems to me that this point of disagreement with Fuko raised by Butler is
answered in advance by food coke.
And that evens there.
When you think about it,
they're really an agreement with each other.
They are,
you know,
it is,
it is Foo Co's,
Foo coast position is more flexible than she takes it to be,
but that just means that it's similar to her own.
Uh,
and as I say,
so that,
that,
uh,
fact together with the broad shared political agenda that they have seems to me,
to,
uh,
to suggest that they're writing very much in concert,
and in keeping with each others views.
Now in method,
they are somewhat different.
Fico is a more historical writer,
although historians often criticized him for not being historical.
Uh,
nevertheless,
that is,
I mean the reasons historians don't think he's historical is that he never
really explains how you get from one moment in history to the next.
He talks about moments in history,
but he talks about them in terms of,
of bodies of knowledge,
epistemically moments as he sometimes says.
Uh,
and then these moments somehow mysteriously become other moments are transformed
and the kind of causality that might explain such a thing,
uh,
from an historian's point of view,
tens in food coast arguments to be left out.
He nevertheless is concerned.
However,
with the way in which views of things change over time.
And it's the change in those views that his argument in the history of sexuality
tends to concentrate on so that he can say that starting in the 19th century and
continuing to the present,
there are essentially four [inaudible] beings around which,
uh,
power knowledge,
deploys itself.
And he describes them as the hysterical woman,
the masturbating child,
the Malthusian couple,
meaning the couple who is enjoyed not to reproduce too much because the economy
won't stand for it.
That's the s which is a way of see of deploying alliance in such a way as to
manipulate and control reproduction.
Uh,
that's a moment by the way in which the deployment of alliance and the
deployment of sexuality may be in league with each other because obviously birth
control and homosexual practices can also control reproduction.
So,
so as you see,
it's not always a question of conflict between,
uh,
between these,
these,
uh,
these two forms of deployment.
So in any case at the mouth is Ian couple and the perverse adult meanings,
the queer person in whatever form.
Uh,
and he says about this on page 16,
34 and the left hand column,
you get,
you,
you get these four types.
Uh,
and he says that therapy,
the clergy,
family parental advice,
the various ways in which knowledge of this kind of circulates,
have to do primarily with the preoccupation,
with tension about anxiety,
about these four types.
The hysterical woman as this is determined to be hysterical once her whole,
once,
once it begins to be thought that her whole being is her sexuality,
the masturbating child violates the idea that children are born innocent,
uh,
as both his is and,
and,
and must because it suggests,
you know,
something terribly wrong about the,
uh,
the cult of the innocent child that begins in the 19th century is something that
is subject to extreme and severe surveillance.
Who knows what will come of this,
uh,
scientific thinking about masturbation had to do with the fact,
with the notion that it led to impotence that,
you know,
by the time you get around you,
you got around to being in a relationship.
It wouldn't be anything there anymore.
Uh,
just terrible thoughts.
Also,
it stunted your growth.
You've died sooner.
You know,
the terrible,
terrible thoughts about masturbation.
All of us,
uh,
dominated the scientific literature until well into the 20th century.
Uh,
the,
um,
and,
and then the Malthusian couple,
um,
which was primarily a phenomenon of what's called political economy and the
earlier 19th century,
but has prevailed by the way,
um,
in,
in what we supposed to be.
And indeed what is our progressive,
uh,
technology of the promotion of birth control around the world.
Uh,
we must control population is still the valproate Malthusian principle on which
we base the idea that people really need to be enlightened about the possibility
of not just having an infinite number of children.
Um,
and so,
uh,
again,
you see that foo co's right still to suppose that the,
the notion of the Malthusian couple,
uh,
prevails,
prevails among us.
And then finally,
the perverse adult,
uh,
who is first discoursed about in the 19th century as the earlier passage that I
read suggested and is still of course widely discoursed about.
And of course now has a voice discourses,
uh,
in its own right.
Um,
uh,
literature,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
sort of a journalism and all the rest of it,
at,
uh,
is in other words,
very much in the mainstream of discourse.
And still has controversy swirling around it precisely because of the discursive
formations that attached to it.
So all of this,
uh,
Fuko takes to be in the nature of historical observation for Butler.
On the other hand,
uh,
as you can tell from her style,
I'm sure that as in the case of Reading Baba,
you recognized a lot of Derrida in Butler's style in Butler.
It's a question of taking these same issues and orienting them more in the
direction of philosophy.
I've already suggested the way in which she understands this particular essay as
a contribution to that,
uh,
branch of philosophy called ontology,
that philosophy of being,
uh,
and in general she takes a particular and acute interest in that and what she
does,
I think by the,
I mean her basic move is something that I hope by this time you've become
familiar with and recognize and perhaps even anticipate,
uh,
for us.
Perhaps the inaugural move of this kind,
uh,
were the various distinctions made by Levy Strauss.
Uh,
the one that I mentioned in particular,
uh,
as accessible.
And I think immediately explanatory of how the move works is the raw and the
cooked.
Uh,
and I,
I tried to show that intuitively,
obviously the raw precedes the cooked,
you know,
first it's raw,
then it's cooked and yet at the same time,
if we understand the relationship between the raw and the cooked to be a
discursive formation,
we have to recognize that there would be never,
there'd be no such thing as the Ra if there weren't the cooked.
You have to,
I mean if,
if you talk about eating a raw carrot,
you have to have had a cooked carrot and then you get,
you know,
you don't,
you don't just pick up a carrot which,
which,
which you've never seen before and say this is Ra.
The only way you know it's raw is to know that it can be and has been cooked
well.
This is the Butler move,
the move that she makes again and again and again.
What do you mean the heterosexual precedes the homosexual?
What do you mean the,
the heterosexual is an original and the homosexual is just a copy of it.
Who would ever think of the concept of the heterosexual,
the heterosexual,
you know,
you,
you're,
you're the only person on earth and you stand there and you say,
I'm heterosexual.
You don't do that.
You're just say,
well,
I'm,
I have sexuality.
Right?
You could say that if you had enough jargon at your disposal,
but you could say that,
but you can't say I'm heterosexual.
You can't have the concept heterosexual without having the concept homosexual.
They are absolutely mutually dependent and w and this,
and it has nothing to do with any possible truth of,
uh,
of,
of a chicken and egg nature.
You know,
as to WordCamp in sexuality,
the Sup,
the very strong supposition is for Butler.
Neither came first.
They're always already there together.
Uh,
um,
in that psychic access,
uh,
with which we identify sexuality,
but in social terms,
the idea that what's natural is the heterosexual and what's unnatural secondary
derivative,
uh,
imitative of the heterosexual is the homosexual is belied simply by the fact
that you can't have one conceptually without,
without the other.
And it's the same thing with gender and drag.
Drag comes along and parodies mimics annotates gender.
But what it points out is that gender is always in and of itself precisely
performance.
I,
you know,
anybody this could of course take the form of a critique I suppose,
but we're all quite virtual Osa when it comes to performing.
Here I am,
I'm,
I'm standing in front of you performing professionalism,
I'm performing whiteness,
I'm performing masculinity,
I'm doing all of those things.
I'm quite a virtuoso,
you know,
I mean it water performance.
Um,
and uh,
and,
and so perhaps it's,
it's kind of hard to imagine my standing here sort of exclusively performing
masculinity as opposed to all the other things that I'm performing.
But okay.
I'm certainly doing that too.
And I'm insecure about all these things.
Butler,
I guess because I keep performing,
in other words,
I keep repeating what I suppose myself to be.
I don't just,
I'm not comfortable in my skin,
presumably,
and I don't just relax into what I suppose myself to be.
I perform it.
Uh,
it is,
in other words,
a perpetual self construction construction,
which does two things at once.
It stabilizes my identity,
which is its intention,
but at the same time it betrays my anxiety about my identity in that I must
perpetually repeat it to keep it going.
All right.
And so all of this is going on in this notion of performance.
So what drag does is precisely bring all this to our attention.
It shows us once for all that that's what's at stake in the seemingly natural
categories of gender that we imagine ourselves to inhabit.
A like a pair,
like a set of comfortable old clothes,
uh,
drag,
which is not at all comfortable old clothes,
reminds us how awkward,
you know,
are the apparel of ourselves that we can call our identity actually is.
Um,
and so it plays that role and the relationship between identity and performance
is just the same.
This notion of performing identity should recall for you signifying in the
thinking of Henry Louis Gates.
It should cough,
it should recall for you.
In other words,
the way in which the identity of another is appropriated through parody,
through derision,
through self distancing,
through,
uh,
a sense of the way in which one is something precisely insofar as one is not
simply inhabiting the subject position of another.
It should also recall for you,
uh,
the sly civility of the subaltern in Homi.
Bhabha is thinking the way in which double consciousness is partly,
uh,
in the subject position of another,
partly in one's own in such a way that one liberates oneself from the sense that
it's the other person who's authentic.
And that one is oneself somehow derivative,
derivative,
a subordinate,
uh,
dependent.
Uh,
and so all of these relations,
uh,
ought to a gel in your minds as belonging very much to the same sphere of
thought.
Uh,
the way in the way in which,
uh,
the,
you can't have the raw without the cooked is the way in which generally
speaking,
categories of self and other of identity per se simply can't be thought in
stable terms in it for themselves,
but only relationally.
Now,
Oh boy,
why is this literary theory you ask yourself,
you have been asking yourself very quickly.
And of course Butler gives the greatest example at the end of her essay when she
says,
suppose Aretha is singing to me.
Uh,
you make me feel not a natural woman because there's no such thing as a natural.
You make me feel like a natural woman.
You presumably being some heteronormative other who shows me what it is really
to be a woman.
But suppose a wreath is singing to me or I suppose she's singing to a drag
queen,
right?
That is reading,
that's reading,
uh,
a song text.
Uh,
in a way that is precisely literary theory.
Now obviously I'm thinking of Virginia Woolf's,
Mr Ramsay and writing the sentence,
it's a terrible sentence for which I apologize,
Virginia Wolfe never would have written it.
Um,
but,
but just,
but just to pass and review the way in which what,
which we've,
what we've been doing is literary theory.
The Marxists critic would of course focus on his,
because the nexus for the Marx's critic in this sentence would be possession.
That is to say the deployment of capital such that,
uh,
a strategy of possession can be enacted.
The African American critic would call attention to white color coded metaphors,
insisting,
uh,
and other words that one of the ways in which literature needs to be read is
through a demystification of processes of causation,
whereby white is bright and sunlit and,
and,
and central and black as Toni Morrison suggesting her essay isn't,
is an absence is a negation,
is a negativity.
This is bad.
A dark mood for the postcolonial as critic.
Obviously the problem is an expropriated,
but also undifferentiated commodity.
Who Oriental you don't mean,
or in huddle you mean Kazak or Bacara or key Liam or any number of other
possible in a,
in,
in other words,
the very lack of specificity in the concept,
uh,
suggests the,
the reified or objectified other,
uh,
in the imagination or consciousness of the discourse.
And finally,
uh,
for gender theory,
the masculine anger of the philosopher,
Mr Ramsay,
you remember,
he could so frustrated because he can't get past our,
he wants to get s he can't get past or the masculinize anger of the philosopher
masks the earthiness of the aesthetic of somebody who has an oriental rug.
And that in turn might mask,
you know,
the,
the feet prophets,
soil type might mask,
uh,
all and altogether too Hetero,
t heteronormative,
sexual predation,
and on and on and on.
Dialectically if you read the sentence as a,
uh,
an aspect or element of gender theory,
okay,
I will certainly end there.
And next time we'll take up the way in which,
what we've been talking about for a few lectures,
the construction of identity of things,
which has obviously been one of the common features of this course is theorized
at an even more abstract level with certain conclusions.